you are bringing joy people every day
because you're doing a thing called with
nail and isolation yeah that's true so
it's a different with nail quote every
day yeah I mean it's happened not by any
clowny it's all just happenstance that's
somebody tweeted and said could you say
one of these lines so I did and then it
snowballed very very quickly and it
became about like a human jukebox
because people have been tweeting and
saying could we have this slider go down
that line so I just done them and things
that are doing that we've put a few
together here they are once you get down
there and have sex with those cows
listen I pay you 10% to do that well
lick 10% of the artists for me then I
have some extremely distressing news
we've just ran out of wine
I like how much you enjoy them well you
know I'm fine it's the only script and
anything that I've ever done and all my
40 years in show business but I can
remember all the lines of dialogue so
they amused me then and they still amuse
me now
[Music]
you